which was initiated in july of this year by
addressing the applications for membership by
great britain and other countries
this
this decision this decision beforehand the discussion
about the progress of the procedure will take place
as mentioned at the end of the debate of 18 19
december that is ladies and
gentlemen  what i can now
tell you in brief and in summary
everyone agreed that
there would be no contradiction that after the
fundamental debate but on this 18 19
december at the end there will also be a decision on the progress
of the procedure there are still
questions ladies and gentlemen yes
its no longer a question of being i
thank you for your interest and
your patience